[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
killer father or innocent man the
shocking possible motive in the murder
of a 13 year old boy
she just was an all well-rounded
good kid just very sweet child
the robert durst trial is back in
session with arguments about durr's
health
will he make it to the witness stand it
had a fight there was an
accident on the stairs something
terrible had happened
as to the charge of first-degree murder
and the perpetration of a felony crime
how does the jury find guilty sir the
verdict for a tennessee man charged in
the death of his five-year-old autistic
son
plus a settlement five years after her
family says police shot their father
while selling cds outside of a store law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and prime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
jury selection is underway in the trial
of a colorado man
accused of murdering a son nearly nine
years ago law and crimes anjana olivia
is here with more
on the death of dylan redwine yeah brian
redwine went missing over the
thanksgiving holiday in november 2012.
it took authorities years to charge his
father mark redwine with his murder
dylan redwine was just 13 years old when
he disappeared during a court-ordered
visit with his father mark
in november 2012 a walmart surveillance
camera captured dylan with his father
the evening he arrived it would be the
last time dylan was seen alive
he was a good kid he was a great kid he
was an easy kid
he was selfless he was very caring he
didn't really like to disappoint anyone
elaine hall dylan redwine's mom is eager
to see the trial for her
ex-husband begin as are those who
oversaw the investigation
dylan disappeared in 2012 we all lost
something
the red line family lost an amazing
special young man
and many of us in our community lost our
sense of safety
trust and security in our own homes the
indictment charging mark redwine was
second-degree murder and child abuse
resulting in death
claims dylan's blood was found in
several locations in redwine's home
then in 2015 the indictment says dylan's
skull was found
and showed evidence of blunt force
trauma
and the trial is taking place in la
plata county colorado that's about
six hours southwest of denver brian
now angenette from what i understand
this is not your typical motive
for a case what do prosecutors in
dylan's family believe the motive was
yeah we've heard that the motive in this
case was the fact that
dylan and his brother may have seen some
photographs on their father's phone that
showed him dressed in women's clothing
and possibly eating
feces out of a diaper and there's
actually a question
about something about that on the juror
questionnaire so it's a pretty
startling motive dylan apparently
according to the indictment had planned
to confront his father about something
right truly an interesting case we'll
keep eyes on that as it continues thank
you very much anjanet
breaking news out of california where
millionaire real estate air robert durst
trial
will move forward despite objections
from his attorneys
durst was hospitalized in the jail late
last week in the middle of his trial for
the murder of susan berman
his attorneys say he has a urinary tract
and blood infection
and can't dress himself so he is forced
to wear jail clothes
prosecutors say durst might be faking it
and has said on jail calls that he plans
to fame dementia
to get a mistrial this is a critical
situation he shouldn't be in court he
should be in a hospital
where and that hampers us as lawyer from
going forward
he's on tape discussing his unhappiness
he filed with the court a letter
complaining about the trial what his
lawyers have stipulated to
he doesn't want to be here he doesn't
want this draw to continue
i'm not inclined to adjourn let's do
what we can
if he has to go home you know we'll go
back to
go go back he'll go back we can i'll
supply
a blanket i like i i i have a blanket i
can give him a blanket
he needs to put a jacket over the back
of him you can put the jacket over the
back
terry there were a number of motions to
start this week of the durst trial
what exactly happened you know the
defense
counsel started out with a motion to get
an adjournment of the trial because he's
saying that
robert durst's health is really bad he
said obviously
that he has a urinary tract infection
that he has sepsis
that he is in a catheter and
has a bag and that would not be
appropriate for
the jury to see he also said that he has
an impaired
immune system and so i think all of
those things combined he's on
pain medication he's disoriented he also
said that
he doesn't know what month it is
apparently
durst thought it was march when in fact
obviously
it's june but you know lewin did not
want to hear that he stood up he argued
against in a german and lewin said
that this isn't the first time durst has
tried to seek an adjournment
he said that he was going to use the
excuse of covet and
use the excuse of demented to get an
adjournment so i think lewin is doing
the best he can to argue for his client
but i think obviously the judge said no
you're here today
we will at least continue for the day
and basically i think they're going to
take it day by day after that absolutely
on one end
the question is is he healthy enough to
participate in his own defense but
i think like our very own linda kenny
boden said that
prosecutor john lewin and the judge will
have this case continue
whether or not you have to bring durst
in a barrel bring him in a wheelchair
bring him in any kind of way
they're gonna go full steam ahead terry
thank you very much
still ahead on law and crime daily
almost five years after the death of a
father
his children reach a multi-million
dollar settlement with baton rouge
officials
but first the jury is out the verdict is
in
will it be not guilty or guilty for a
tennessee man accused of killing
his five-year-old son
[Music]
welcome back we're headed to tennessee
for the verdict in the joseph ray
daniels trial
the man accused of killing his
five-year-old autistic son joseph clyde
daniels who is also known
as baby joe the jury may have found the
father of three not guilty of
first-degree murder
but they didn't let him off the hook for
the death of baby joe
daniels was convicted of a lesser
included charge of second-degree murder
as well as first degree murder and
perpetration of a felony
aggravated child abuse initiating a
false report and
tampering with evidence his second
charge first degree murder and
perpetration of a felony is the most
serious
and carries a life sentence sentencing
of the 31 year old will be september
14th
law and crime host jesse weber got a
chance to speak with daniel's defense
attorney jake locker
after the verdict here is what he had to
say
i can't say that we were completely
surprised since they did bring in
a alleged live witness kind of at the
last minute
prior to the trial we had no
information that a brother was going to
be testifying
once the brother testified
it made it clear that the jury could
reach a verdict like they did so i can't
say i'm surprised
i'm glad they did not find my client
guilty of premeditated murder
well i think the jury did the best job
they could with what they had
i do think there were errors committed
in the trial
i think some of those areas are
reversible areas we will be filing an
appeal to the court of criminal appeals
and it's our hope that we'll receive a
new trial how's your client doing by the
way after the
verdict he's doing well
he's anxious to start the appellate
process
and i've told him we'll have to go
through citizen we'll then have to argue
a motion for new trial
and then we'll have to file the appeal
and he knows that that'll take time and
that
if he gets a new trial it would probably
be next year at the earliest
joining us today is civil rights
attorney jeff storms and terry austin
jeff does this affect crystal daniel's
case the co-defendant
who's charged with lesser charges uh and
should we expect to plea or trial from
her
you know brian i think it puts
significant pressure on
her defense attorneys and on her you
know a jury
already has not believed um
you know uh his story uh
and she's there you know through
investigators she's placed there at the
scene
and so i think that you know another
jury is gonna have a hard time believing
that she didn't have some understanding
that the child
was being beaten um and was in danger
and that she ignored that danger yeah
it's gonna be difficult to point the
finger when the other person who's
you're pointing to was already convicted
for sure
tara you've been watching the trial from
day one are you shocked about the
verdict
and do you see any of these uh appellate
issues that the defense is raising
could overturn this case and have a new
trial
you know brian i think the jury got it
right i don't think this was
premeditated but
we did get the lesser included murder
charge and the felony murder charge
and plus all of the guilty verdicts on
all of the other charges
so i think that was the right outcome i
don't see any grounds for
appeal i think judge david wolf was one
of the best judges i've ever
seen at a criminal trial i think there's
absolutely no
legal error here he let in daniel's
confession that might be one of the
areas and i think that was correctly let
in
he also excluded some other testimony so
for instance one of the neighbors
it was hearsay the judge said the mother
of the girl
who might have heard something she said
that that was
something her daughter said and the
judge said that that was not reliable
and that it was
hearsay so i definitely think that the
verdict is going to stand i don't think
there are grounds for appeal or new
trial
and so i think we're going to just go
straight to sentencing and that will be
that
yeah we'll definitely see the sentencing
and see what arguments the defense does
raise
in terms of appeal in that case thank
you and now to texas where officials
have charged a dallas man with capital
murder
in the death of a four-year-old boy
eight-year-old darren brown is accused
of kidnapping and killing castron
last month investigators added the
capital murder charge
after finding the child's blood on
brown's clothing and sunglasses
according to a new report brown was
already facing kidnapping and theft
charges
after home surveillance footage showed
him taking the boy from his bed
a jogger found the boy's remains the
next morning jordan's twin brother was
sleeping next to him
when the four-year-old was kidnapped
police say the child suffered a violent
death from a quote
edge weapon brown is being held on 1.6
million dollar bail
coming up on law and crime daily one
witness to george floyd's murder
has been given a prestigious award plus
would you take the stand in your own
defense at trial
we speak with dan abrams about his new
show featuring defendants who did
just that your sneak peek into court
camp presents under oath
next
[Music]
welcome back one of the most compelling
moments in any criminal trial
is when the defendant takes the stand
law and crime founder dan abrams is here
to tell us about his news show featuring
compelling testimony
you don't want to miss it is incredibly
rare for criminal defendants to take the
stance real suspects accused of murder
it's a high-stakes gamble very few tapes
delivering real testimony in their own
defense
do you acquire the knife and the zip
ties
never leave home without them will they
stand the pressure or fold
under oath you put the gun ventures
law and crime viewers should recognize
some of the cases
uh that you cover on under oath right
absolutely
um you know you'll see look some cases
that people will
remember like the jodi arias uh case for
example
but then you're gonna see other cases
like um you know two of the
cases that i think were the most
interesting uh both of which were law
and crime stories with the tammy moore
case
and the lindsay parton case um both
cases of
women tammy moore accused of killing her
husband's girlfriend and in the case of
lindsay parton
a babysitter accused of killing a
three-year-old girl
in both of those cases one of the
reasons i found these to be the most
interesting cases
was because it was unclear whether they
did it
and there was a real question um
about um you know well wouldn't they
not take the stand that tammy morris
sits up there and tells you
everything that she says happened so
those are the cases i i found to be the
most
interesting were the ones where it was
really close
and the defendant's testimony really
made you say hmm
you know i i wonder is is this person
guilty or not
but this is really telling you how we
got there
as well as the defendant's decision to
take the stand
the whole show is all based around
this defendant this person who's
choosing to take the witness stand
but there's always a story behind it how
the person got there
um there's surveillance footage there
are 911 calls
there are videos etc that all sort of
help you piece together what you think
happened and
in the end the viewers can decide
because i can tell you even behind the
scenes
the producers have debated oh you know i
didn't think this person did it or
i think that that was a fair verdict or
not a fair verdict and i think that the
reason
you often see that kind of passion
coming from the producers is because
they've now all seen the defendant
testify
they've heard it from his or her own
mouth
and it kind of allows you to have a i
think an even more
passionate opinion about guilt or
innocence than if a defendant doesn't
take the stand as is
the case in in most murder trials
interesting cases and stories in that
under oath airs wednesday at 10 p.m on a
e when we come back a settlement in the
police shooting of a father of five
how much facility will pay ahead
welcome back the teenage girl who shot
the viral video of george floyd's arrest
and death
has received a prestigious award darnell
frazier was walking to cut foods last
year with her nine-year-old cousin
when they stumbled upon the arrest
darnell started recording the video with
her cell phone
and posted it on facebook it went viral
sparking protests and outrage around the
world
darnell has been awarded a special
pulitzer prize citation for quote
courageously recording the scene and
highlighting the crucial role of
citizens
in journalist quest for truth and
justice
terry let's go right off the bat what
are your thoughts on frasier receiving
this special citation
and how did you feel that the pulitzer
prize board described her actions
well you know i think it was a
well-deserved award she was only 17 at
the time
she had her nine-year-old cousin with
her
and it was difficult you know she sat
there and she in fact
videotaped the whole thing she posted it
on social media
and if you recall brian when she
testified during the trial
it was difficult to her she felt guilt
and she
felt as though she had not done enough
and i think it's important that she
is recognized here because i think it
will help
with the fact that you know she feels so
bad about the whole situation
and i think she actually did a lot for
everyone here this case would not have
gotten to the point where it did with
the conviction so
i'm glad she got it congratulations well
done
now jeff you and i met in minneapolis i
know that you are also representing
uh dante wright i want you to talk to us
about the importance
of citizen journalism and filming these
types of incidents for people like
darnell frazier
and how that's changed the criminal
justice system
brian the highest burden of proof in the
criminal justice system is beyond a
reasonable doubt
unofficially when it comes to holding
white law enforcement accountable for
excessive uses of force or crimes
particularly against people of color i
think unofficially
it's some higher standard that is beyond
all
certainty or with a hundred percent
proof
uh they they hold these uh officers
in really such a scheme and are afraid
to be skeptical of them
and so in order to combat that sort of
these natural inherent prejudices that
exist
against holding law enforcement
accountable for excessive use
of force on people of color we need
people like her we need that video
evidence
because without that video evidence a
lot of times we see people in the united
states
just turn their brains off they accept
whatever the character assassination is
they accept whatever the law enforcement
version of events
is and these citizen journalists
have provided the evidence necessary
to start holding people like derek
chovin accountable
and their bravery cannot be commended
enough
absolutely thank you for that and now to
louisiana
where the family of a man shot and
killed by police in 2016
has reached a settlement the city of
baton rouge will pay alton sterling's
five children 4.5 million dollars
police shot sterling six times in 2016
after receiving a call about a man with
a gun
selling cds outside of a convenience
store a lawsuit claimed the 37 year old
civil rights were violated
and cited negligence in the training of
officer blaine salamoni
he was fired but later allowed to resign
another officer involved in the shooting
was suspended
the officers were not criminally charged
in addition to the settlement
the baton rouge police force has
promised to make several reforms
now jeff this is somewhat connected as
well sterling was killed in 2016
and the case just got settled is this a
victory for the family even though the
officers are never criminally charged
well first brian i'll say on the civil
side it is a tremendous result
there were some hurdles that uh that
chris stewart and his team were going to
be facing in that case
and i think they did an excellent job
for that family
criminally uh you know there were two
investigations and that's because there
was really troubling conduct but
ultimately no
charges and the problem i have with
these cases is that prosecutors usually
come forward
they look our families in the eye and
say well you know i can only really
prosecute cases that i believe that we
can win
but for any of us who've been involved
with the criminal justice system
particularly again when it comes to
people of color we've seen prosecutors
overcharge time and time again and put
it into the hands of the jury
and so when there are these close call
situations
involving law enforcement i don't know
why the default
is always to say we don't think we can't
we can win so we're not going to bring
it
as opposed to say let's give it to a
jury and decide these close call
questions
that we haven't even you know bothered
to prosecute really
for decades absolutely now terry after
sterling's death
city officials rewrote the police
department's use of force guidelines
something the family applauded what's
your take on the changes in the city
you know i think it's important brian
not to just have a large settlement
because that's important to the family
obviously it doesn't bring anyone back
but it does help with expenses et cetera
but when you have
that in conjunction with changes to
policies changes to practices
then i think it really does make a
difference
one of the things they said that this
was going to do was to make sure that
there's additional training on
de-escalation
that there are verbal warnings before
using deadly force
and that the officers really are
prohibited now from using choke holes
and from firing into moving vehicles so
if those changes are made here
and if we see those types of changes i
think in other jurisdictions
it will be helpful changes to their
practice and hopefully enforcement both
sides providing a change
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you